[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAM SILVERBERG:
Welcome, everybody.
My name is Sam Silverberg.
I'm a cloud engineer
based in Portland, Oregon.
And I'm lucky enough to have
my brother Aaron Silverberg up
on stage with me.
We're going to be
presenting about Cloud ML
Engine for industrial
vision inspection.
But before we get
started, I just
want to talk a little
bit about how we
got to this point, which was--
my brother and I were
discussing all of the advances
in object detection
and machine learning.
And Aaron is in the
industrial space.
And we thought this
is a good opportunity
to team up and come
up with a fun--
make it a fun opportunity
to work together.
AARON SILVERBERG: Thanks
for the nice intro, Sam.
We don't really
get the opportunity
to play LEGOs and GI
Joes much these days,
so for us to be able to
work together on something
like this is fun.
Flexible Assembly Systems
is based in San Diego,
and we specialize in
designing and building
custom robotic equipment
for various manufacturing
industries, whether it be in
automotive, bioscience, medical
device, aerospace,
defense, et cetera.
And one thing that all of these
industries that we work with
strive for is better
quality, higher throughput,
better safety standards, and
the ability to log vision data.
Now, I have a short video I
want to share with you guys that
goes through how machine
learning, machine
vision, and automation
all fit together.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Welcome to Flexible Vision.
- Give me sunflower seed.
- All right.
Getting your sunflower seeds.
- Hey Google, use
Flexible Vision.
- All right.
Here's the test version
of Flexible Vision.
Welcome to Flexible Vision.
- Give me a peanut.
- All right. getting
your peanuts.
- Hey Google, use
Flexible Vision.
- OK.
Let's get the test version
of Flexible Vision.
Hi. what can I get for you?
- Give me a candy almond.
- All right.
Getting your candy almonds.
AARON SILVERBERG: Are
you tired of digging
through Costco-sized
big nut containers
looking for your favorite nut?
Well for me, this was
happening all too often,
and I had to make a
drastic change in my life.
[END PLAYBACK]
And with a little
help from Google,
now my life runs efficient
as the Department
of Motor Vehicles.
But in all seriousness, machine
learning and machine vision
really do have the
potential to change
the world for the better.
So what does peanuts and
almonds have anything
to do with machine learning?
The answer is machine vision.
Machine vision today is a
$10 billion global industry,
and is expected to be
$18 billion by 2025.
In North America
alone, the industry
has grown 10% this past year.
This market is really broken
up into two product categories.
We have the PC based systems
and all in one smart cameras.
These PC based systems have a
lot of horsepower capability.
You have the capability of
plugging in multiple cameras,
being able to run all
the cameras in parallel,
and then you also
have the flexibility
of being able to swap
out lenses and lighting
to cater it to your vision
inspection application.
And on the other side, we have
the all in one smart cameras.
They're a really
nice, tight package
that have everything built in.
They have the processing, the
lighting, and the lensing,
all in a nice form factor.
But you do lose out
on the horsepower,
and you are limited to,
obviously, the one unit
for your location.
Now, these are
real life examples
that I have up on screen.
The first example
is a medical device
that we were doing 100%
inspection on these products
as they were going out the door.
And it's a silicone
injection molded part that
was prone to under molding.
And this under
molding would be--
not enough material was injected
in the injection mold process.
And so we had two cameras
mounted perpendicular
to each other, taking a picture
simultaneously, and getting
a throughput of one per
second on this operation.
The second example is an
automotive application.
This is an electronic device
that goes into vehicles.
And there's a process that
requires thermal paste being
applied to this product before
it goes into the automated
machinery.
And so we decided
to use an all in one
smart camera for
this application
to detect that thermal paste
and give the robot the OK
to go ahead with the operation.
Another way these cameras are
used is for robot guidance.
This is an example of a camera
mounted on the end of a robot
to give it coordinates
on where it should go.
And this is doing
server assembly,
and we were looking
at some fiducials
on the printed circuit board to
decide where those parts could
go with great accuracy.
And other examples might
be picking and placing
car bumpers from a rack
onto a moving assembly line,
picking and placing horns onto
a sub assembly, inspecting
a bead of adhesive
to verify that it's
a solid bead of
adhesive, and then
being able to read
barcodes and OCR.
Here I have up on screen two
examples of today's programming
interfaces.
And on the left I have a-- this
is more of a drag and drop.
This is, you have your palette
of tools that you would drag
and drop onto your screen
and create your program
in a tree-like structure.
And over on the right
hand side is an example
of more of a spreadsheet
style programming, where
you can import
functions and do more
of a programming
in a spreadsheet.
Both are based on the idea of
having a palette of tool sets,
being able to pull those
tool sets into your program,
then manipulate them.
And the thought has
always been to--
in order to add more
capability, add more tool sets.
Now, I'm going to quickly go
through kind of today's process
on how we program
vision systems today.
And essentially
what we're doing is,
we're looking at a bitmap
image of a picture.
There have been
advancements in the industry
to triangulate between
bitmap locations
to give you higher accuracy that
this is the image that you're
looking for.
But essentially what
we're looking at
is taking an image bitmap
and comparing it to one
that we've trained against.
First step is to
define your camera
lighting and lensing, and
adjusting your aperture
for your application.
Then we can go into
the programming.
And programming, one of the
first steps we typically do
is the calibration.
If it's going to be used
in coordinated motion
between a camera
and a robot, you
want to be able to
take those coordinates
and give them real
life coordinates
that the robot can interpret.
Then you'll use, just like
we talked about a minute ago,
we'll use the drag and
drop from our palette
on the screen to
create our program.
For example, these palette tools
might include a circle tool.
If you were trying to define a
golf ball moving down assembly
line, you might use a circle
tool to tell the system, hey,
I'm looking for round object.
Or a dispense bead, you might
use the line tool for something
like that.
Or a histogram tool if you're
trying to figure out how
bright or dark something is.
And you'll add these tools
and create your program.
And you might include
some pre filters
to make those pixels pop
out a little bit better.
And then it's ready to run.
And we run through the
snap and find routine.
And it's not really until we
get to those thousandth one
that we really feel comfortable
with hey, this program
that we created is going to
work for our assembly line.
And keep in mind
that false positives
are a part of life
in this industry.
So why is that?
Well, the systems today are
suspect to lighting conditions.
We have-- imagine you're
in your factory floor,
you have a skylight,
and the lighting
changes throughout the day.
Well, you have to account
for that in your software
program and your vision program
so that, as those lighting
conditions change, that you
are still successfully finding
the model as you intended.
Camera orientation is important.
If that camera
happened to get bumped,
that is an environmental
issue that you
might have to overcome.
And, like I had mentioned
earlier that the operators--
because you have
these false positives,
operators on the assembly line
tend to open up tolerances
that you've built into
your software program
to alleviate their jobs to
get the product out the door.
But what they're really
doing is opening up
the opportunity
for failed product
to be going out the door.
It's also very difficult
to detect any object
with variability.
Like you saw earlier with
the peanuts, anything
organic like fruit
is very difficult.
Castings are another
difficult object
to find, because sometimes
they come out shiny, or dull,
or have additional
flashing on them.
And logging of data
is such a value,
and it's underserved
in the market
today, mainly because
it's not accessible.
The application
is there, but it's
up to the engineers that
are building their software
programs to make that
connection to the cloud.
What if vision systems were
less difficult to maintain,
easier to share programs
across factory floors,
camera resolutions weren't
as critical, lighting
and environmental variables
were less of an issue,
systems were less expensive,
and the same system
that you're at home sorting
LEGOs with your children
is the same system that you're
using at an automotive factory
to detect scratches on trim?
Is open source the solution?
Well, TensorFlow is a great
object detection tool.
OpenCV is good for
measurement and calibration.
Node-RED is a good
logic control and allows
you to connect to
peripheral devices.
Tesseract OCR is the number
one optical recognition
software available today,
and ZBar is a good tool
for reading barcodes.
But not one of these
is a silver bullet.
Each one of them comes with
its own steep learning curve,
and integration between
them is non-existent.
We wanted to crack this
nut by democratizing
the industrial vision market.
Removing the technical
barriers to entry,
literally harnessing
the ML Engine
and bringing it on Prem when
needed, simplifying the setup,
creating an all in one, easy to
use graphical user interface.
I wanted to make it
flexible and modular
by providing an open API, being
able to use any USB camera,
and keeping it low cost
by keeping it open source,
using low cost CPUs
in edge devices,
being able to train in the
cloud instead of on Prem.
Integrated cloud and
open source is the future
to industrial vision.
We are super excited to be
releasing an open source
version of Flexible Vision which
meets all of our democratizing
objectives.
It has endless market
potential, opens
the door to use cases that
weren't previously available,
whether it be to
pricing constraints
or functionality in the market.
Vision models can now be shared
across factory floors globally,
and version control is built in.
The system is automation ready
and can communicate directly
with robots and PLCs
on factory floors.
I have a short
five minute video.
I'm going to go
through the software,
and then I'm going to
pass it over to Sam.
And Sam's really going
to go into the ins
and outs of the
software and how we're
using Google Cloud and
Google components to bring it
all together.
So the very first thing
that we're going to do
is we're going to
plug-in a USB camera.
And it shows up automatically
under connected devices.
And then you'll see
we can see the camera,
and we're going to
change the resolution.
We can go up to 4k
resolution on this.
But keep in mind that
the lower the resolution,
the faster the processing.
And this is an optional step,
but the camera calibration
is required for robot guidance.
So we can take
the pixel location
and convert it to
millimeters, and also
take any SKU and
angle rotation, so we
could pass that
information to the robot
so it can pick it up correctly.
And then if we go back
to the camera screen,
we can see that
it is calibrated,
and we could see the conversion
from pixels to millimeters,
and the rotation
that we saw earlier.
All right, now the fun stuff.
We're going to create
a project, and we're
going to call this Nut Training.
And the next step
is to start taking
some images of these nuts.
So we're going to
select the camera
and select the project
that we want to associate
all these images to.
And we're going to sprinkle
out some peanuts, randomly
oriented.
Take a snapshot of that.
And then we'll sprinkle
out some almonds.
And we'll do that one more
time with some walnuts.
And now we're going to move
into the image annotation.
This is where we're
going to tag the images
and tell the system what
each one of these items are.
So we do have some
icons over on the left
that tell us that these images
have not been tagged yet.
And we have a whole lot of nice
tool sets built into this GUI.
But the very first
thing we'll do
is we'll create the tag names.
And this tag is going to,
first of all, be peanuts.
And we're going to
do a box detection.
And just simply drag and drop.
We're going to go through
and select these peanuts.
And then we'll do the
same thing for almonds.
And like you saw earlier when
we were creating these tags,
there were a few other checkbox
we could have put in there.
There's object detection,
which we're doing right now.
We have OCR and barcode
reading all built in.
We also have some other tool
sets like a zoom feature, which
allows you to, if
you're trying to do
a small components on a PCB
that were difficult to see,
we have this lure that
you can drag and drop.
And now we're ready to start
the augmentation process.
This is where we're going to
take just these three images
and augment them and
give them some variables
to create thousands of images
from these just three images.
And click Export Data.
Here we have a pop up box,
which gives us some variables
that we could punch
in if we wanted
to change how these images
were being augmented,
if we want to be able to rotate
them or scale them differently,
we can put those
parameters in here.
But the default settings
seem to work pretty well.
And you'll notice at
the top of the screen,
we have an indicator that says,
hey, something's going on.
This pre training is a
pretty quick process.
It only takes 30 seconds or so.
And you can see that
that's been completed.
And we can go to
the image data set,
and you can see that now we
have those thousands of images
created.
Then we're going to take
these augmented images
and export them
for model training.
Again, we have a
small dialog box that
allows you to change
a few settings,
but we'll just keep
it, again, as default.
And this process
happens up in the cloud,
and it can take anywhere
between 20 minutes
to an hour and a half, depending
on the model that you're
training.
And we will come back,
and now we have--
we'll see that if we go to our--
excuse me-- list projects, we'll
see that the project is done,
and we can assign a model to it.
The reason we did
it this way is we
wanted to have that
version control built in.
So in a future date, as
you're refining your models
and making them
better and better,
that you can go back
and update that.
And now we're ready.
That's really the last
step, and now we're
ready just to capture and run.
Select the camera.
Select the project that
we're interested in running.
And there you have it.
It's that easy to
create your models.
This is-- you'll see
in just a minute here,
we're going to break apart
some of these walnuts,
and the detection is
absolutely amazing.
And with that, I'm going
to pass it over to Sam.
SAM SILVERBERG: So
what I'm going to do
is, I'm going to go through
some of the concepts that
were required to be
understood in order to make
all this happen as
well as the underlying
architecture from both and on
Prem and from a Google Cloud
perspective.
But before I do, let's talk
a little bit about Flexible
Vision and what Flexible
Assembly is releasing today.
And it's an open
source package that
provides end to end training
all the way through prediction.
That includes
camera calibration.
It also includes object
detection, object localization,
OCR scanning, and
barcode scanning.
And it leverages ML Engine in
the cloud, Google Kubernetes
Engine to perform that
augmentation and training
process, Google Cloud Storage
to store the images, obviously,
in persistence, and
then finally, on Prem,
we're doing the prediction.
This is what the overall
architecture looks like,
and specifically, what
you saw in the case
of the initial
video Aaron showed,
which is that, all the
way on the left here--
so on the left,
yeah, on the left
is the robot or the IoT devices
that you will be manipulating
the data from the camera.
In the middle, or
the next over, what
you have is the workflow engine.
The workflow engine, in the case
of what we did, is Node-RED.
so Node-RED is a
nice drag and drop
tool to do IoT
integration, but it
can be any host of
different tools there.
And then you have your
local prediction server.
In case of Flexible
Vision, microservices
are heavily leveraged.
And each one of the
different components
is actually a docker
container in and of itself.
Now, prediction locally on
Prem is important, specifically
for industrial applications,
because you need very quick,
sub 100 milliseconds
cycle times.
That round trip
time to the cloud
may not suffice in
those circumstances.
And finally, all the
way to the right,
you have all the components
that are in Google Cloud.
You have everything from, like
I said, Kubernetes Engine,
it's responsible for training
coordination and augmentation,
Google Cloud Storage,
that's responsible for all
the persistence,
ML Engine that's
doing the actual
training itself,
and then finally, what
you saw as Aaron initiated
the entire process
using Google Home,
initiated through Dialogflow.
And that's also
represented here.
So let's talk about the
main underlying concepts
that's required as
part of this, as far
as what you've seen today.
And that is object localization,
or object detection,
commonly referred to.
There are a lot of
open source libraries
that allow you to
do object detection.
But the one that was
selected for this project
was TensorFlow
Object Detection API.
This is an open source API
that's provided by Google
and is on GitHub.
And it essentially
provides bounding boxes
around images as well as what's
called instant segmentation.
What I mean by bounding boxes
is what you see in this picture
are those boxes around
the images themselves
that identify what
those objects are.
Like I said, there's a lot
of object detection models.
But let's drill in just
quickly on a couple examples
and how this all works together.
There are two steps
to this process.
There's actually quite a few,
but the first big step here
is actually identifying
candidates for objects
that you're going to want to
do some detection process on.
And let's talk about
single shot detection.
Single shot detection
is a very fast method
of identifying
objects and images
by using a small convolutional
network to come up
with candidates of
possible objects
that could be in that picture.
This is really useful
for small form factor,
low computational power systems
such as cell phones or TPUs,
edge TPUs.
It's not so good at
detecting small objects,
but it's fine at detecting
larger objects and pictures.
The second method
is Faster R-CNN.
And this works differently
than SSD in that
it doesn't use a single shot.
It actually does
post-processing of the image
to find potential candidates
in those pictures.
And the way it works is finding
anchor points in those images
and detecting foreground
versus background
to come up with those
possible candidates of objects
in those images.
Once those candidates
are identified,
the second step is actually
to do the prediction.
That is, what is in
those objects themselves.
And that's the
same whether you're
using SSD or Faster R-CNN.
Let's talk about two possible
methods for doing that.
There's quite a few,
but these are two that
are probably the most common.
The first is ResNet.
ResNet is a deep neural network
that can go to 101 layers
and beyond in
terms of its depth.
It's very good at
detecting detail.
It's very good at accuracy
of detection in an image.
The second is Inception.
And Inception, instead of being
deep, is a wide neural network.
There are also deep and
wide neural networks
that are Inception-based,
but essentially, you
can kind of think of them
as rather than going deep,
going wide.
Regardless of what
neural network
you decide to attach to
the detection process,
you're going to want
to measure to see how
accurate these networks are.
And the primary
way of doing this
is, we're using what's called
the mean average precision.
Mean average precision
is a combination
of the three elements that
you see here in the slides.
The first being precision.
That is, are the
objects in the picture--
are they what they're
telling me they are?
The second is recall.
Is it seeing everything it's
supposed to see in the picture?
And then finally is
intersection of union.
Intersection of union measures
how much of the bounding boxes
around the object.
Is it too much area,
is a too little area,
or is it just right?
All three of those components
are combined together
to come up with this
mean average precision.
And you'll see this quite
often, as an example,
what you see here, in terms
of measuring accuracy.
The second key component
is, once you've
identified those
objects, now you
have to put them in real space.
And how this is done
is by translating
those pixels, where the bounding
boxes are, into millimeters.
In addition to that,
you need to orient
the robot, in the case of
the video that Aaron showed,
to the camera so that they're
oriented in the same location
at the same angle.
And this is all done through
a calibration process.
Now, the way that
Flexible Vision does it
is by using a checkerboard
to do the calibration.
What I mean by calibration
is, identifying
the angle of the
camera to the surface
that you're doing
the detection on.
In addition to
that, you want to be
able to align the
rotation of whatever
is the device that's doing the
pick and place with the camera.
And that requires a second step.
In the case of Flexible
Vision, that alignment
is done using a QR code.
Why is this important?
Because, like I said,
object detection
is the basis upon
which its inspection
industrial applications using
machine learning will be built.
Once you've identified
an object in space,
you can then do OCR scanning.
You can then do
barcode scanning.
You can then do pick and
place and quality assurance
on those objects, because
you've correctly identified them
and you have
confidence that they
are what they say they are.
So that's why that
process is so important.
So now we're going to go through
step by step in a little bit
more detail about what's
happening under the covers,
and why all these steps are
required in order to do object
detection.
And the reason this
is important is,
it doesn't matter if you're
using the open source Flexible
Vision or if you guys are
building your own tool.
The steps are essentially
going to be the same.
And the first step in that
process is doing the tagging.
This is the idea of
dragging and dropping
bounding boxes
around the objects
that you're most interested
in, into pictures
that you've collected.
In the case of Flexible
Vision, those pictures
are collected from the work
cell that you're actually
going to do the detection
at, or you can upload them
to Google Cloud Storage.
In either case, once you've
collected those pictures,
you're going to want to do
this bounding box process.
And the bounding box
process basically
does three essential things.
It identifies the
objects for training.
It also identifies a
label that you want
associated with those objects.
And then finally, you're
going to select an action
that you would want performed
once those objects are
identified.
Those actions might be
just strictly identifying
the object, or it
might be, again,
doing OCR scanning
or barcode scanning.
One question that
comes up quite often
is, how many objects
do I need, or how many
pictures do I need in order
to get a good training.
And that really depends
on the type of objects
that you're doing detection on.
As an example, luckily,
in the industrial space,
many objects are well-defined in
terms of their edge and shape,
and they don't vary very much.
In those cases, you may
only need 3 to 10 images.
In other situations, where
you're doing quality assurance
and the type of failures
may vary quite greatly
between different
scenarios, you may
need quite a few
different images
or samples of those in order
to get a good training.
It may be up to 100 images.
The second step to this
process requires two phases,
and we call it the
training process,
but it's actually two phases.
The first is doing
image augmentation,
and the second is to actually
doing the machine learning
training itself.
Image augmentation is not
always required, but is really
nice to have,
because what it does
is it reduces the
variability associated
with environmental variables.
Like Aaron mentioned,
if you have a skylight
and the lighting might change
day to day during the day,
or if the camera angle,
at the time that you're
doing the training, is
different than the camera
angle at the time that you're
actually doing the detection
and production, having
done this augmentation
is a really nice thing to have.
What it essentially performs
is skewing or scaling,
image contrast, or rotation.
Another nice aspect of doing
this augmentation process is,
you might take a sample of
size of, say, 100 images,
and it might explode
to 1,000 images based
on each augmentation has a
new image in and of itself.
So you actually end up
with a larger sample size.
And once you have
that process complete,
then you would actually go
through the training itself.
Now, the training
itself is fairly
straightforward from
the perspective of,
you've already done
all the hard work.
The training is done all
by ML Engine in this case.
Now, what happens
on the back end
is that ML Engine
is spinning up,
in the case of Flexible Vision,
32 simultaneous GPU servers
to perform a training
in about an hour.
Now, if you compare that to what
if you ran it on your own GPU,
that might take 16 hours.
The other benefit of this is
that, once you do the training,
if you need to retrain,
it's very quick as well.
So it's a good benefit
to doing it that way.
Now let's talk about
the third step.
The third step in this
process is actually
to do the prediction
in production.
In order to do this
prediction in production,
let's talk a little bit
about the flow itself.
And let's talk about
what Aaron showed
in that first video,
that is, the picking
and placing of the nut.
So he initiated that
process using Google Home.
Google Home, then,
triggered Dialogflow,
which is in Google Cloud, which
then triggered a Pub/Sub event.
A Pub/Sub event is a
topic that is listened to
by external sources
that contains some data.
That Pub/Sub event was
listened to by Node-RED.
Node-RED, again, is an
IoT workflow engine.
It's open source.
But you can use any IoT
workflow engine in this case.
Once it was triggered, it
then called the REST API
that was on the Flexible
Vision server that
said, take a snapshot and
return to me the bounding boxes
associated with image objects
that you found in an image.
With that, Flexible Vision
then triggered a snapshot
from the camera, returned
back the results that
were found within TensorFlow.
Those results included
the bounding boxes
and some binary digit associated
with the bounding boxes
themselves.
Flexible vision then
used that information
to return back the location and
space, that is, the location
in millimeters, the textual
label associated with those
bounding boxes, in addition,
it will return back OCR scan
or barcode scan data as well.
All that data is
returned back to Node-RED
in the form of a JSON document.
And then finally, Node-RED
then commands the robot
to move to a specific
spot based on a midpoint
of a bounding box, and
then returned back the nut
in question.
So now I'm going to turn
it back over to Aaron,
and he's going to
close things up.
AARON SILVERBERG: Thanks.
So we are super excited to
be releasing this software,
and we really can't
wait to see what you all
use this software for.
With Flexible Vision, we've
simplified the process.
We've democratized machine
learning and machine vision.
And again, we want
to see, in education,
we would want to
see universities
using this technology and taking
it out into the workforce.
We can't wait to see
pathologists and radiologists
using this technology
to find rare diseases.
And in the industrial
space, we want
to be able to change and collect
the data associated with all
of our customers' needs.
And at home automation,
we can't wait for you
guys to find out when
you're low on milk.
So with that, we appreciate
everyone's time today,
and thank you very much.
I'm going to open up
to questions, Sam.
SAM SILVERBERG: Yeah.
We're open to questions.
If anybody has any questions
on implementation details
or other aspects.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]